the tuesday afternoon session the first
speaker is going to be ryan o'donnell
who will talk about testing surface area
thanks rocco thanks for inviting me to
this
uh okay here's what you need to know
this marker is not very good
this is a
giant work with
uh kothari
nayari
me and cheong gong woo
and uh actually i don't normally give
acknowledgements but i'd like to
actually acknowledge adam clivens who
has contributed a lot to the early
stages of this work
okay so uh the title you can kind of
guess what the subject will be but i can
tell you the motivation it actually came
from a paper
uh that i wrote with clavin's and uh
rock closer video
in 08 and it was a learning paper
and uh the lettering result in that
paper was the following
uh
let's see be the class of all sets
f
in rn
with surface area at most
s
and actually this learning result we
were thinking of rn as having the
gaussian distribution because it's quite
natural in high dimensions especially
for learning so in fact um i actually
mean the gaussian surface area here
which was mentioned in el canon's talk i
want to define it but basically you
integrate the gaussian pdf over the
surface
and the results in that paper is we gave
a learning algorithm for this class in
fact it was an agnostic learning
algorithm
in two seconds what that means
learnable under the gaussian
distribution as i said in time
and to the order of s squared
okay and that's uh pretty nice there are
actually quite a few sets that have
surface area gaussian surface area at
most an absolute constant like the set
of all ellipsoids of any size has
surface area at most one so that would
give a polynomial time algorithm
any polytope with polynomial n many
faces has square root log n surface area
so it gives an n to the log n time
algorithm for this class
and this agnostically means that
actually the set doesn't actually have
to have surface area at most s
you can talk about non-convex things uh
actually
the set of all convex sets is also
interesting they have surface area at
most and to the one-fourth
so that gives you a running time that's
like uh and to the root end
sub-exponential even for them
but you can also get results for
non-convex sets
uh well uh basically the the model is
that you get uh examples so you get
randomly drawn gaussian points from the
gaussian distribution and also whether
or not they're in the set
and after you know about this many draws
and time you have to output
a hypothesis set which is close to the
true underlying set f
in gaussian measure
and actually this agnostic
aspect means that it works even in a
very challenging era model where you
don't have to assume that the unknown
set has surface area at most s
even if it's only
90 percent close to such a surface uh
such a set like if you take a set of
surface area s and change it on 10 of
gaussian space
this algorithm will still find a good
hypothesis that agrees with the set on
you know 89 percent of gaussian space
okay so that was the learning result um
now the running time is you know can be
a little bit slow so this is actually i
think a good example where this
motivation for property testing of
testing before learning makes a lot of
sense it might be reasonable if you're
given let's say black box access to this
set f you can query a point and see if
it's in the set or not to first try to
check really quickly if it has surface
area at most s or it's close to having
surface area at most s and then if it
does then you might want to actually run
this you know medium fast algorithm
okay so this is our motivation to try
and uh answer this question
uh so more precisely what do you mean to
do
test surface area in the property
testing framework
uh you want something that looks like
this so
sort of the input you have black box
access to a set
f
and let me say let me this was about the
gaussian setting and we're going to
actually eventually talk about the
gaussian setting here too but let me
stick with the more familiar setting of
the normal surface area and normal sets
so let me just for
scaling say that it lies somewhere
inside the unit cube just so you know
where to look to start
what i mean there's an unknown set f
that your sort of promise lies you know
inside the unit cube and you can query
any point in the cube and find out
whether or not it's in f
and you're also given a
target surface area s and some error
parameter epsilon
and what does the algorithm do it can
like query
q randomly chosen points not necessarily
uniformly random from the cube but
according to some clever
distribution and learn if they're
in f or not
and after it does that and does some
computation has to either output yes or
no
which basically means whether or not it
thinks the set
f has surface area at most s
okay
and the goal in property testing is
mainly focused on the query complexity
you want to minimize q
although our algorithms will also be
fast
we'll have results for uh both but let
me just focus on the standard levitt
surface area
um
okay so
no here the algorithm has the property
that it actually doesn't use queries it
just uses purely uniform independent
random examples and it uses about this
many queries too or uses about that many
examples and time
okay and it just does an output yes or
no for some reasons it has a two things
that it's trying to satisfy
the first one is called completeness
and this means that if the unknown set
actually does have surface area at most
s the target
then you should output
yes with high probability
let's say at least i don't know
99
you can boost that to something higher
if you want
and
as usual in property testing the
soundness condition is slightly more
subtle
you can't just say that if it has
surface area bigger than s then you
output no with high probability
and i'll draw a picture explaining why
shortly but
if you're familiar with property testing
you'll recognize this kind of thing
we want that if
if f not just has a small surface area
but f is epsilon far
from all sets g
with surface area at most f s
then the algorithm should output no with
high probability
okay
and uh what does epsilon farm mean here
we just mean that uh
the volume of the difference is at most
epsilon
okay
and actually
in property testing it's usually nicer
to think about the
contrapositive of this condition so let
me write that
equivalently
you want to be the case that if f is
such that the algorithm outputs
yes
with probability even at least one
percent
it should mean that there exists a g
which is epsilon close to f
such that
uh the surface area of g is at most s
these are equivalent
no
no
in fact the important thing for us uh as
i'll say now is actually there's no
assumptions made on f at all
okay so for example you know this is
basically like you're giving black box
access to a set and roughly speaking you
want an estimated surface area which is
quite similar to
you you know this a long body of work in
markup chains literature about
estimating the volume
of an unknown convex set that you're
giving black box access to
it's not hard to show that uh if you can
do that you can use similar techniques
to estimate its surface area this is
done by belkin haryanan and miyogi
um
but
this is quite different model because we
don't assume convexity at all we don't
assume anything at all about f
um
will your other algorithm be able to
find
so to learn some uh
body with sponsor
area close to us
yeah so that's a good point that i was
gonna say i mean this actually fits
quite nicely with the fact that the
learning algorithm is has this agnostic
property which means that you don't
really have to have the set you know
have surface area at most s as long as
it's um
epsilon close to having surface area at
most s the algorithm will run in time as
though it has surface area s
the information can be discrimination
yeah
yeah so i mean a good a picture to keep
in mind um so actually this problem is
almost equally interesting in two
dimensions as it is in n dimensions
unlike the case of the classical you
know estimating volume problem so a good
picture to keep in mind is like
here's the cube in two dimensions and
you could have a set that's like maybe
it starts to look like it's a nice
convex set but actually has some like a
weird tentacle here
uh which has
you know by making this really thin you
can have like negligible volume which
means that like a black box query
algorithm will like never notice it but
it has like you know constant surface
area this can be quite
actually arbitrarily large surface area
okay so because of you know the
possibility of like the these tentacles
for example you kind of have to work in
the property testing model if you want
to work with absolutely no assumptions
about the complexity of the set
okay there's a slightly other slightly
more subtle other problem like you could
have a set that looks like this and has
like some super wiggly bounce okay some
super wiggly boundary at a small scale
you can make the surface area or
perimeter in two dimensions arbitrarily
large by making this very wiggly but
like
you know if the
that's the negligible area difference
from just a flat side so a black box
algorithm can't really notice it
sort of it seems like the volume is at
least epsilon otherwise
right if the volume is not so for
example testing volume in this uh setup
is easy because you just have to query
about one of our epsilon points randomly
and see if you notice uh
something and as mutter says actually if
the set f happens to have volume less
than epsilon then by iso parametric
inequality surface area will also
basically be less than
no sorry the other way around actually
right it steps on close to the empty set
which has surface area zero
okay
um
good
um i should also add yeah we have
results
when
f is just a subset of rn
and
surface areas gaussian surface area
but i'll just stick with the euclidean
case
okay any questions about the model
the problem
okay good because i'm going to add one
twist
which will allow us to state our results
and also the previous results i'm going
to make the java tester a little bit
easier because in some sense we couldn't
prove everything out we wanted
so i'm going to insert a factor here
kappa
times s i'll call kappa the
approximation factor
which ideally would be one um
but it's not such a big deal for us
it'll be something like 1.3 so it's not
a crazy big factor but it just shows you
know you only have to distinguish things
that have surfaced around most s from
ones that are far from having surface
area maybe a little bit bigger than s
okay so that'll make our job a little
bit easier
okay still okay with the setup
it's not clear that cap is necessary in
fact i'll show you you know some results
have no cap though just cap equals one
no no yeah
that wouldn't make my life any easier
okay so let me tell you about prior work
so this problem was first appears
in a work of kerns and ron from 98
just in the case n equals one
okay which is still non-trivial so n
equals one means you have a set that's
somewhere contained inside the interval
maybe it's this
and its surface area is just uh
well the number of endpoints or twice
the number of intervals so this is the
problem of you're giving black box
access to a subset of the line you want
to test whether or not it's a union of
at most
s over two intervals
okay so they uh worked on exactly this
problem they
on one hand achieved very good query
complexity one over epsilon but actually
their approximation factor was one over
epsilon which is very large
okay so they can only tell the
difference between like s intervals and
s over epsilon intervals
um
this was improved and uh essentially
improved in a recent work by balkan blah
blah and yang
they also only focused on n equals one
um but they had no approximation factor
i mean they just solved the problem
precisely copy equals one
and their query complexity was
polynomial it was one over epsilon to
the fourth so that's great i mean they
solved it for one dimension
no we'll see the algorithm in a second
it's um
well you'll see the algorithm in a
second okay and i'll tell you our
results so
uh we looked at higher dimensions which
actually as i said
it already becomes quite interesting in
the case n equals two
and really all the main ideas are in
that case
um
although we also got something for
n equals one i suppose
uh we got you know
kappa equals one with
very slightly better query complexity
this is not a big deal
but we actually got
for any
kappa that's strictly bigger than 1
we got
a
linear complexity
okay so the this hides a constant that
depends on how much bigger than one you
are it's like
polynomial
uh so that's good if you allow yourself
a little bit of slack then you can get
even a linear query complexity
uh but we also got results for higher
dimensions so for n equals two
um
actually all our results are basically
linear query complexity
this is for any
kappa which is strictly bigger than i'll
write kappa 2 which is
32 over
3 pi squared
that's a
1.08
for n equals 3 we got the same
linear query complexity for any kappa
bigger than
kappa 3 which is 9 8
which is 1.125
and in general we got for general n we
got this query complexity for any kappa
greater than kappa n which is
anybody see the pattern 1 32 over 3 pi
squared 9 8. what's the general case
no i'll give it
it starts with a 2 yeah 2
n plus 1 squared
n over 2 choose negative a half squared
oh there's no square here
no i mean this is the this is like the
most compact and jokey way we found to
write it it's really like the ratio of
some gamma functions
uh but
you can theoretically express it this
way
yeah so uh it goes as n goes to infinity
to four over pi
which
yeah which actually was uh very cool to
us we didn't expect this and what it
means is this is you know one point uh
something
1.27 maybe
it means kind of this uh in some sense
you know evades the curse of
dimensionality i mean for all n you just
get this one result if you allow capital
to be 1.27
linear query complexity so this is kind
of surprising to us
no no it's really just uh uh
if you want to get kappa n plus eta then
the query complexity is 1 over epsilon
eta 2.5
okay so uh that was neat we did we were
certainly at first willing to you know
tolerate something that involved n but
it turns out you don't need to
okay oh and also oddly enough in the the
gaussian case the result is
just four over pi for every dimension
and the same linear query complexity
okay so let me uh
yeah
uh i think so actually we didn't quite
think this through i mean there is the
issue of that it's only like epsilon far
from being but i mean i think you can
just try this for different values of
s and i think that will do something
i didn't think about it though
yeah you have to worry if your set has
an epsilon set on which you can change
the service
yeah
i didn't think it through um it's worth
thinking through i should add that you
know it's probably indicated there's
actually no reason to believe that you
need such an approximation factor and
one reason i want to talk about this
result is like i think it's a very great
question to just get it you know capital
equals one there's no real
reason why this kappa is necessary
in fact our algorithm may always already
work we just don't analyze it correctly
okay so about this algorithm uh after a
little thought
well does anybody have a suggestion on
how you would try to estimate the
surface area of an unknown set using yes
very good thank you alcanon
i might even phrase it a different way
i'll get to the noise sensitivity but uh
as buffen's needle
okay so i mean um
actually just remember the setup let's
say we have f it's a subset of well i
would write 0 1 to the n but actually
for technical reasons
it's a little bit nicer to
let it be in the torus
rather than the solid cube then you
don't have to worry about like
whether if it sets on the boundary does
that count to the surface area or not so
just imagine that these things wrap
around anyway it's not a big deal
and let me also write f for the plus or
minus one indicator
of this set
so uh you know buffing's needle you drop
the needle it helps you estimate the
surface area right so uh
basically the at a high level the wave
often needs to need to work is you pick
a random
needle that just means a line segment
let's say x y
of length delta think of it as small
okay so it just means you pick like a
random point in a random direction and
you go y
from x to y maybe that's one that's one
that one that one etc
and then uh one thing you can do is
try to see if it crosses the boundary at
least in the property testing model it's
natural to just
query f of x
and f of y that's two queries i mean
let's check if x and y are in
and check if they're not equal
uh because after all what is the surface
area really but you like
look at all the points that are within
distance delta of the boundary
take the volume of that and divide by
delta and let the limit just take the
limit as delta goes to zero so
this kind of idea seems plausible
for small delta
um
right
so
this is i guess the idea behind buffon's
needle but there's also a theorem
associated to it
which is precisely the following
if you do this experiment then the
expected number of intersections
between the needle
x y
and the boundary of f
okay you shouldn't just look at whether
or not it intersects you should look at
the number of intersections because it
could intersect the boundary more than
once
is exactly equal to
the surface area
or perimeter in two dimensions
times the length of the needle
times the dimension dependent constant
which i'll write beta n
this thing uh i could say what it is
explicitly but let me just
remark that it's on the order of one
over root n it's one in end in one
dimension
and um this is not too hard to prove you
should think about why it's true or try
to prove it uh let's say when f is a
polytope it has flat sides
and you can think about why this is true
yes yeah this is a known fact from
integral geometry holds if f has like
piecewise c1 boundary
yeah this is koshy crofton formula or
something
yeah so that's a theorem
and uh
it suggests why an algorithm that does
something like this might be a good
idea but
in fact if you think about it at first
you think oh this is great i mean the
surface area up to this factor that i
know and the factor that i know is just
this why don't i just estimate this
empirically
well the problem is you can't easily
count the number of intersections
between the needle
and the boundary
part of the dimension one problem yeah
but you do have something that you can
say
you can at least say that
in this setup the indicator that f of x
does not equal f of y
is less than or equal to the number of
intersections
okay because if they're not equal this
is zero nothing matters if they are not
equal then it has to cross the boundary
somewhere now the thing is this could be
not equality right i mean it could cross
the boundary two times and then these
would be not equal or four times so it's
just an underestimate
but there's an intuition at least that
somehow if delta is
small enough it should somehow be
unlikely to cross more than once
okay but the fundamental problem with
like turning this into an actual proof
and algorithm analysis is
understanding what does it mean small
enough
okay
um
there's actually one other
more minor issue
uh besides sort of
understanding sort of how small does
delta have to be so this is
approximately
correct
uh
there's a problem that even in one
dimension right let me draw a tricky
example here
imagine the set looked like this
it was sort of
kind of periodic looking
all these intervals have the same width
and the same length of gap between them
and imagine delta is this distance
and you see no matter where i put this
delta length needle either both
endpoints will be in or both will be out
so you'll always be counting 0 on the
left hand side even though the thing has
large surface area and large area
okay
but this sort of the issue is a more
minor issue you can sort of easily get
around this by
instead of always picking a needle of
length exactly delta you know randomize
a little bit the length of the needle
and that'll help you solve this problem
okay
so i hope that's a motivation enough for
the
whole algorithm which i'll now state
so i'll state the whole algorithm and
give a sketch of the analysis and then
we'll be
done
um
in order to state the algorithm though i
need this notion of noise sensitivity
which
uh elkanon suggested
and i should also add that this uh idea
of using noise sensitivity was
uh
crucial to this
statement i erased here the bbby paper
bled all or balkan at all
um
the idea of using noise sensitivity to
do the test and analyze it came from
that paper actually
even though it's only one dimension
so let's define this is slightly
non-standard notation but i hope you'll
be okay with it
i want to define t delta of f
that's another function from let's say
the torus
into the interval minus 1 1.
it's just its value
our point x is the expected value
of the indicator f of y where y is drawn
not just the random point at distance
delta from x but a random point in the
ball of radius delta center dot x
okay so if let's say this is the picture
here's the set f
uh little f is plus one inside and minus
one outside the value of
t row or t delta f at this point is
you average the indicator around a
little ball here so just be one
probably around here would be around
zero because about half the points are
in and half the points are out
etc
and with this in hand we can also define
the noise sensitivity
of delta at f
to be
this the probability when x is drawn at
random from the torus and y is drawn
from the ball of radius delta around x
that f of x
does not equal f of y
okay so this is exactly like this needle
experiment except you're sort of
randomizing the length of the needle
okay and in fact let me just make a
little comment here
that uh
in this definition the expected length
of x y
is delta times does anybody know what
the expected length of a point inside
the unit ball is
that one has a simple formula it's n
over n plus one
is the expected length of a vector
chosen randomly from the interior of a
unit ball
okay so that's
the definition of noise sensitivity and
we can also write it in a way that
involves these other things we just
defined
that's the same as the expected value
over a half minus a half times f of x
f of y
because this whole thing is the
indicator that f of x does not equal f
of y
which is a half times the expectation
over x
of one minus f of x
times t delta f of x
yeah these are all the same thing yeah
this seems very sensitive but this
measure seems more robust
is that true
well
this is i mean this event is kind of
doing the exact same thing is talking
about the exact same thing as this
except it's just randomizing the length
of the needle a little bit
i guess so
okay so now i can state the actual
algorithm
um
it's just the same idea as this
okay so the actual algorithm is your uh
in step zero
you're given access to f
and epsilon
and the target surface area s
and given these parameters you set delta
to be something
i'll say later
um
and then step one you just empirically
estimate
the noise sensitivity
of little f at delta
okay using
it turns out that it'll be enough to use
order one over epsilon many queries
okay so you just do this experiment a
bunch of times make two queries and
estimate
okay and by turning off you'll get a
very good estimate so it's basically as
if you actually knew the noise
sensitivity at delta of f
um
well it actually depends like how big uh
this quantity i'm trying to estimate is
and i actually won't eventually get into
the exact details of the query
complexity but it's all standard turn
off stuff
maybe actually it'll become clear in a
second
okay and then finally step two
uh
having estimated this just say yes
if and only if the estimate
is at most 1.01
times beta n times s times
n over n plus one times delta
okay
so
let me first uh
pardon me
this switch
beta n is yeah from this thing
so this is set up so that the
completeness of the test will be clear
well
i'm not clear but
it'll happen automatically from this
theorem
uh so the point is let's assume that you
get like a acura a completely accurate
estimate of the noise sensitivity which
you do by turn off
um
then buffer's needle tells you that
the noise sensitivity which is the
empirical estimate of how often this
happens will be less than or equal to
the expectation of how often this
happens
and if the true surface area is at most
s then this will be at most
you know beta n times s times delta
times well not times delta but times the
expected length of the needle and as we
saw here the expected length of the
needle is n over n plus one times delta
okay
so
any questions about the completeness
but now we come to the i mean this is
set up this is always an underestimate
so this will be okay
now we come to the main question of like
hopefully somehow if delta is small
enough
this is maybe approximately correct or
not too much of an underestimate or what
have you
okay
so the soundness
that was crazy thank you the soundness
is uh okay so actually i should tell you
how you said delta
in fact how you said delta
you set delta so that
this thing is epsilon
delta is set
such that this quantity
is
0.01 epsilon
and that's basically why order of one
over epsilon queries are needed because
you're estimating something that is
you're basically trying to tell if it's
on the order of epsilon or not and you
don't mind a multiplicative factor of
1.001 so that's why of one over epsilon
is okay
and the soundness theorem
is that if the noise sensitivity
of f is at most 0.01 epsilon
then
there exists a g
which is
those two properties first it's surface
area
is at most
dimension dependent constant kappa n
which is like 4 over pi
plus 0.01
times
s
and the volume of f symmetric difference
g
is at most epsilon
okay
all right so
in the remaining seven minutes i'll try
to sketch the proof of this
okay so uh
let me make one quick observation
the hypothesis of this theorem is that
you know epsilon is bigger than or equal
to the noise sensitivity at delta of f
okay and let me use uh this formula here
so that's bigger than or equal to
uh a half times the expected value over
x of one minus the absolute value of t
delta f of x
okay just using the fact that f is at
most one in absolute value
okay and the assumption is that this
quantity is at most you know basically
epsilon
which means that this quantity absolute
value of t delta f of x which let me
call this g of x
is basically almost always plus or minus
1 on average okay roughly speaking this
hypothesis means that this g of x
is sort of always
plus or minus one maybe minus plus
theta of epsilon
okay so it's sort of almost always one
or minus one and furthermore it's sort
of this thing
more or less always agrees with
uh f of x
it's mostly one where f is
cluster one where f is one and close to
one is one where f is
minus one
so you might imagine in this picture
remember
here f is plus one everywhere inside
this set and minus one elsewhere
g is maybe going to be like plus or plus
one
sort of well inside the set and it's
going to kind of tail off to around zero
here it's going to be kind of -1
everywhere outside this set
maybe it'll even be close to minus 1 on
this little tentacle it'll kind of
smooth out
okay
so what we have to do given this fact
the g is kind of always close to plus or
minus one we need to build
capital g out of little g
in such a way that has small surface
area and also it's similar to f
now a natural idea is like
okay we need to build capital g out of
little g so any place where like little
g is plus one we should put that into
capital g and any place where it's minus
one we should you know declare that to
be outside of capital g
you know if you're close to plus one
maybe you should also be in capital g
you know if it's on the gray area maybe
you're not so sure but
it's okay it's rarely sort of in the
gray area so actually in some sense
satisfying this condition is not very
hard but satisfying this condition is
hard like you have to build a g that has
small surface area
so somehow like you have to like thread
the needle you know you want it to be
this part to be outside of g this part
of the inside g you kind of have to
figure out how to put in like a
small surface area set here
and we spent some time thinking about
how to do this and it was getting really
complicated seeming
but then we resorted to the
maybe the obvious idea which
somebody might be able to suggest can
you suggest maybe a strategy
yes you should look at level sets super
level sets and you should do it randomly
because you know what else you're going
to do right the probabilistic method
uh
yeah so the idea is
to define g
would be the set of all x where g of x
is bigger than some threshold theta
where theta is chosen randomly
and i should say if there's like one
part in this paper where i think we did
something a little bit smart and can pat
ourselves on the back
it's to have the idea of not choosing it
uniformly randomly but the way that
makes it work out quite slickly is to
choose it from the triangular
distribution
for a reason you'll see
uh
you know this the distribution with pdf
this pdf
okay so somehow a little bit more biased
towards being around zero than plus or
minus one
okay so this is our strategy actually it
would still work if we had chosen it
from the uniform distribution we just
get worse parameters
i think i can erase this
as i said the second condition that the
set g you get out
is uh similar to capital f
it's not tar it's very easy in fact
basically because of this observation
that g more or less agrees with little f
so in fact showing that the expectation
over theta of f symmetric difference g
is at most epsilon is easy
let me skip that you can even show that
it's at most this with high probability
just using markov or something
but the main thing is to show to bound
the expected value again over theta of
the surface area of
g okay because it's kind of constructed
in somewhat weird way and we're going to
show that it's at most this and
expectations so
probabilistic method if we make this
high probability then
uh the right g will exist
um
no
actually we don't even use
yeah i mean
you can pay a little bit here with
markov and then suffer a lot here with
markov it's actually even what we really
really do is like change this so it's
like this
uh and then we get this holding with
probability one
but there's a variety of simple ways you
can do it
uh but what are we gonna do about this
the expected surface area of g so
remember you know basically think of g
like a terrain this is two dimensions
little g is like this function that's
minus one between minus one and one
and like we pick a random
height
and we take the
all the the other set where little g is
bigger than that height and then we're
interested in the surface area of that
um
even though it seems like a complicated
construction
there's actually simply like an exact
formula for what this is
does anybody know the name of this
theorem
yeah who said it yeah we got a real
mathematician back here this is the
uh the co-area formula
uh
and it just gives you an expression
it's
equal to the expected value it's going
to basically equal the expected value of
x
of the length of the gradient of little
g at x
actually it'd be exactly this if i
picked
theta according to the uniform
distribution maybe up to a factor of a
half
in general if you don't take it
according to the uniform distribution
you should put in a
phi the pdf
of g of x here
this formula looks a little opaque
but i highly recommend you think about
this formula let's say in the uniform
distribution case
in which case this pdf is simply
constantly a half and that factor goes
away and n equals one
so imagine you really have
here's n equals one little g is some
function that looks like this maybe
and the experiment is like you pick a
random height
theta
and you look at the surface area of this
set
set where it's bigger than that
so you look at the surface area of this
set which is like one two three four
five boundary points
and in expectation that's the same as
the average length of the derivative of
g
um so it's fun to see why that's the
case think about like a particle
traveling here and you're measuring the
total distance it drives with the
expected
length of the derivative it's like you
can measure how far the car drives by
like picking a random point and seeing
how many times the car crosses that
point
in two dimensions it's a little less
easy to see but it's some kind of like
fubini theorem that lets you measure
sort of g's height by like crossing it
by cross sections
anyway it's a theorem which luckily
helps us out and actually makes our work
almost done
yeah so this gives an exact expression
for this
and we need one little claim which is
not hard
um how are we going to bound the length
of the gradient of g well i claim that
g
is
o of one over delta lipschitz
and this o actually depends on the
dimension n in fact it's like one over
it's like root n but
don't worry about that think about two
dimensions if you want
and that's because what is g it's t
delta f
and so the x if you're thinking about
what lipschitz constant it has you pick
two points at distance delta
you average little f in a ball around
this one you average little f and a ball
around this one
well those averages can't be too
different if delta is close because f is
bounded between -1 and 1.
in fact
the max it could be is just the total
variation distance between the
probability distribution which is
uniform on this ball and the uniform on
this ball and the balls like overlap if
delta is small
okay so you can just uh
compute it you know the overlap depends
on the dimension it's something like
root n but it's
it's one over delta is the lipschitz
constant
yes
yeah
um so with this in hand we're kind of uh
in good shape
because
this g is lipschitz so i mean that just
immediately shows that this thing is
like at most
okay this order one over delta
let me let me put in the root the
dependence on n root n over delta so we
get that this thing
is at most
okay order root delta n over delta
times the expected value of phi
which i erased but it's the triangle
distribution
so this triangle distribution is phi of
t equals 1 minus absolute value of t
so we get expected value of 1 minus
absolute value of g
okay and that's exactly this
so this is at most
2
root n over delta
times the noise sensitivity at delta of
f
okay and the thing that our tester
tested if you remember the algorithm
we're basically done now but the thing
that our tester actually tested is
whether or not the noise sensitivity a
delta of f
is at most
beta n times n over n plus 1 times the
target s times delta
so if the tester passes
noise sensitivity is bounded by this
so the deltas cancel
the n over n plus 1 is basically a
constant
and i told you this is like theta of 1
over root n
so the root n's kind of cancel and
eventually you get that this is some
dimension dependent constant but it's
actually constant for all n times uh
s
okay and if you work through the things
very carefully this is exactly the kappa
n which is
got this funny formula that's one
luckily in dimension one
and it increases to four over pi's n
goes to infinity
um
okay so that's it i think a good open
question is try and get rid of this
kappa n and it could be that the
algorithm already does it we just need
to improve the analysis
okay thanks
this is not to be delta that you choose
kind of a random ball a random point in
the in the desert ball
right
yes yes so if you play around with this
does that kind of change yeah that's a
very natural idea you should play around
with this it affects things in two ways
this n over n plus one is coming from
the average length of a point drawn from
that distribution and it also enters
here in the
total variation distance between the
distribution
centered here and the distribution
cellular delta away
and by trying different distributions
you can
make things well potentially better or
worse the best we were able to make them
was by taking it to the uniform over a
ball
it was it was about the same as gaussian
i think if n is high dimensions if for
constant dimensions for example in one
dimension if you do it with the ball and
you're very careful you get one out here
which is great you can't beat it and i
think the only way you can get one this
is exactly what happened in eric's paper
is by using uniform distribution over a
ball which is just an interval in one
dimension it's worse if you would use a
gaussian
for the analogous result for testing
gaussian surface area
we
naturally use the
gaussian noise sensitivity with the
ornsteinullenbeck thing
and when you do all the calculations you
get 4 over pi out and that's the best
distribution we could think of there
on close to a body with surface area so
much
yeah if you have a body and gaussian
space
and it's like noise sensitivity is like
um
there it's like root belt instead of
delta but we know that the gaussian
noise sensitivity
is always
less than or equal to surface area times
root delta times some funny constant
and this kind of tells you that the
inequality also goes the other way if
you're willing to be epsilon close to
having small surface area
you lose another factor of four over pi
and the epsilon
is whatever noise sensitivity a delta
itself is
basically
i think
so yeah kind of allows you to reverse
this inequality relating gaussian noise
sensitivity and gaussian surface area
that might have a good question did you
guys think you're all about extending
this to the boolean cube with like the
notion of surface area for substance of
the cube that alkalone mentioned oh
uh nope we did not
yeah it's a similar
flavor of problem yeah so maybe you
could try that